[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
laurence merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté
ce duplex téléphonique avec moi non j'ai
tellement l'habitude de vous voir en
duplex ce bon alors je vais pas y aller
par quatre chemins
vous connaissez par un qu'obama un petit
peu un petit peu bon ben on compte sur
vous on a besoin de se débarrasser de
l'autre abruti quel abruti alain moussy
connaissez beaucoup des routes i am a
pas mal mais quand même et je l'abruti
sont marina
voilà exactement
d'accord par l'anglais s'il est mineur
ils ont qu'il a il à son petit niveau
quoi
[Musique]
thank you mister president 58.5 mais sa
présence est convaincu ouais ok c'est
bon je crois que wall street is angel
poli wall street dont je sais c'est
formidable ans l'arrêt
austin les champs seulement olivieri
week-end
bon tel point qu'une mauvaise nouvelle
chamerois personne n'a critiqué tirer de
tout le week-end aucune sortie
médiatique ras du tout l oumma cache
rien à se mettre sous la dent eh bien
personne même pas brusquer personne
incroyable arthur n'ont même pas de
chavannes rien georges pernoud personnes
georges beller personnes me luxe norme
et non personne doit quelqu'un en
dessous personnes personne ne fait rien
daphné burki a peut-être dit rien du
tout je te dis donc tu t'es un an
côté musique je vais pas me taire parce
que tu as mal aux yeux patrick bauwen
non à la foule mais j'ai peut-être une
idée qui pourrait lui sauver
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
blessés voulaient pas de la repasseuse
brochard jamais avec le ventilo là j'ai
reçu des photos et j'en ai monté de
bande annonce très compromettantes
car voir ces limiteurs qui affole le paf
regardé par les millions de
téléspectateurs il a fait la une de
stratégie ce soir cyril hanouna en slope
le confort
après moss ou cyril hanouna la presse à
sa réputation n'est pas coulé j'y
comprends rien
[Rires]
[Musique]
car il a officiellement le boulaire le
mcs booba regarde sur quoi je suis tombé
communiqué de passe de ouf tmp meilleur
talk show toutes chaînes confondues - mm
h x et y devient pas maire de cavaillon
[Rires]
tu as envie de passer si bertrand j'aime
ça ouais t'as pas tout vu voici les
communiquer parce que l'on a échappé les
pmp leader chez ma mère mp premier
talk-show l'univers tout planète
confondues et celui-là assez directe des
pmp bim dans ta gueule d'antoine de
caunes raid est clair oliver eu l'air
hier un article dans le dossier santé
sur les maladies qui font mal au pipi je
n'ai pas lu oui oui je lui journal de
mickey sans mal oui j'adore j'adore
qu'est-ce que tu ailles trouver et de la
figure du roi qu'il y ait un dossier sur
celui qu'ils appellent le boss du poste
dilemma gobain exactement lui-même et on
y apprend plein de choses intéressantes
je cite 15 heures j'arrive à des huit
jeux préparés pemper sélection les
vidéos qu'on montrera le soir et en
choisissant les thèmes des débats à tant
de petites secondes
je reviens chez les messieurs vous
dérangez pas vous cherchez des vidéos de
chats qui pète un sondage express
secours et lui sert il aujourd'hui à la
télé oui non mais mon bureau est ce que
vous l'avez vu
pour remettre le kimono bureau je sais
pas j zay le journal de mickey il
explique qu'il arrive ce jour à 15h on
peut pas les missions à la rédac céré
lot bureau
oui camille une excellente nouvelle la
france va enfin découvrir le vrai visage
de cette pourriture dans le canard
enchaîné un article qui explique comment
cyril savonne la planche de corée où
qu'ils se tournent le vendredi au niveau
des audiences week allant des mauvaises
invités envoie deux privant de directs
et surtout engendrant les trois
meilleures chroniques la mienne la
tienne est celle de jean luc tu te
rappelles ailleurs c'est bizarre
pourquoi est ce qu'ils disent que je
fais pas de chronique vendredi j'en fais
bien eu un bon faveur trompe en disant
une bêtise on sait pas qui est la top on
ne sait pas calé de l'intérieur c'est
toi qui parles c'est simple je dis juste
on ne sait pas que ça vienne l'intérieur
à ce propos vendredi qui sont les
invités
alors tu reçois daniel pichardo est
quatrième ce sont ces les animateurs de
radio monop ça fait un petit buzz dans
les supermarchés et au niveau des des
chroniqueurs on a des bons oui ben beau
bata françois viot 1 et hervé martin
ils tiennent une boucherie dans le nord
voilà apparemment ils ont du bagout
cyril voulait que tulle et est juste on
va parler de quoi dans l'émission
apparemment moque si elle vous a préparé
un petit débat sur la couleur du logo de
gulli est une compilation de bouc qui
pète n'a vraiment pas envie que le
remplacement qu'est ce qu'il fout encore
celui-ci
désolé c'est l'architecte fatou de
l'elecam oui le classement des
personnalités préférées des enfants
et croyez moi à côté de ça le canard
c'est de la gnognotte nominables je veux
combien c'est pour moi merci vraiment
pigeon jusqu'au bout si si
dites-moi verdez vous seriez pas un peu
foutu de ma gueule
ma vie promis du sulfureux dans le
journal de mickey l'élu en long en large
en travers et le seul truc qui me
dérange c'est que ça fait vingt minutes
que je suis sur l'énigme plutôt donald
et j'arrive à trouver qui est le
coupable
dernière fois qu'on collaborent ensemble
tout cas mon vieux oui c'est ça oui mais
retourner sur 20h foot foiré bon je vais
pas y aller par quatre chemins on va
avoir besoin de vouloir vraiment besoin
d'un coup de génie
il dit qu apparemment il est pas super
chaud pour musée des beaux coups
derrière le rongeur
on va changer de ton alors et ça késako
1 les sets je tapais la forme un audard
lecomte des fleurs lui a fait payer à
lille en passant dans les quads ça et ça
fait pas mal à ton petit coeur le
rongeur alors toujours pas nous et les
longeurs et sisteron comprends pas ce
que vous dites articulé jeu qu'aux
campagnes apparemment on lira tous
étaient en prison il va mettre tic et
tac sur le coup ok compte sur vous tu me
mets deux places au parc
[Applaudissements]